oh it has been a little bit cooler right
and spring is typically the start of
pool season but not everybody's in a big
rush to take a dip Mary Jane bellies and
joins us live with how local businesses
are reacting to this cooler weather Mary
Jane
yeah we'll take a look at this I mean
the trees are blowing and there's a nice
breeze in the air it feels really nice
out here but not everyone is enjoying
the cold a local pool contractor says
this winter-like chill is drying out
business
the rain and cold weather has made it
the start of a slow pool season usually
they open the pools on April 1st it's
supposed to be at 75 degrees they hit at
the pool at 80 285 but because it's to
call Luis Bernal manager of lindley's
pool and spa services pools around the
valley I believe the homeowners the HOAs
the people who are using the pools
they're impacted because they debating
if they open or not they pulled on time
Trevor Boucher lead meteorologist at the
national weather service in Las Vegas
tells me we have started off much cooler
this year than in years past this is one
of the only four times in our recorded
history have we actually seen 75 degrees
not be reached in March probably looked
outside and seen a lot of days where
it's been cloudy and rainy and that's
not usual for March despite the rain it
may come off as a surprise that southern
Nevada continues to remain below average
for rainfall we've certainly seen above
average days that we've had potential
rainfall or rainfall in the valley but
it just hasn't been enough to be
accumulating to be above average the
same can't be said when it comes to
snowfall it's been great for ski resorts
the Sierra Nevada is well over 200
percent of their annual snowpack up in
that area and then the spring mountains
have also seen well above average as
well but that's where all the moisture
is gone as for Bernal he thinks it'll be
another few weeks until you can be in
your pool I usually end during the
weekends we see a lot of pool a lot of
people using the pools around 15 20
people even in the in the shade even
they've been common sunbathing we don't
see nobody now
now we haven't hit 75 degrees just yet
and without that warm weather Louise
Bernal believes it won't be until May
when pools fully open to the public
reporting live Mary June bellezza 8 News
Now